Hey,
hey, hey.
Wow. Okay.
Let's go.
Don't just move your
arm. Don't just make your arm go like
that. Okay? Your your pelvis
moves. So, this is just my arm. And you
can see how my pelvis will stay still.
Okay. And
instead I want to
move your pelvis moves laterally and
vertically.
So it goes back
under. I'm making him push like he's
pushing me
here.
Okay. So I get grounded and he gets
lifted.
What you're doing is you can sit above
the ground and you can push her.
Okay? Or you can sink in into the
earth and have her push
herself. Guys, can you see that
difference? So, here I am. I'm pushing
her. or I sink down and have her push
herself like a push-up. Okay. When she's
here, she's pushing herself off the
earth. She goes flying.
Okay.
One,
two,
one, two. Okay. So, don't don't use your
arm.
You
want him to be pushing himself over. So
I
ground. So my arm is pretty relaxed
here. You
see it's not
I mean, that's pretty goofy, huh?
Okay, but this is
delusion. Come on.
We're going to take this concept, the
lifting and the grounding and the
pelvis, okay? And of course the hand
work. And we're just going to change it
slightly. So
boom,
hold. And you'll get not just the
lifting you were getting,
but a small little niko variation.
here. I stayed there because I want the
center line. I don't want to be on the
outside when he's got the center line.
Okay? I have the center line. Do you
guys see the difference? If we open up
the technique,
where would you rather be? So when I'm
here, she has an incentive. Hold on. Cuz
she's checking me. Do you understand? So
in her goal to stop me from hitting her
face, she exposes the wrist to the wrist
lock. At the same
time, that's where the elbow
is. You see?
Okay. Now her grip is loosening from the
wrist lock. And I just step through and
I'll push through the grip right to the
elbow. Don't reverse your
motion. That's a lot to ask for in a
fight. Oh, I come back here for no
reason and then I'm going to grab her.
It's going to be there when I get there.
It's not going to be there when you get
there.
Use the wrist lock to get out of the
grip. Don't peel the hand off and then
come in. That too is a joke.
Oh, baby.
So, when you train, you have previous
knowledge, right? You have in your head,
EQ, okay? And it's getting in the way of
what you might be seeing.
Okay, first of all, you should know the
name Eeko. It it's it's everybody has a
different
Eyeo. So, which Eeko is there? What's
the will the real Eeky please stand
up? Okay. And also more techniques are
not named in Iikido than are named in
Iikido. So, what's in the name?
Nothing. So, the golden rule is don't do
the one you think we're doing. Who's the
one we're
doing? Eat what's on your
plate. Okay. So, please watch because
I'm not doing the eco you think I'm
doing. So, we're working right on the
ratio of of hand work, footwork, right?
Okay. So, here I am, right? And let's
say my grounding power, you know, like,
okay, in this case, maybe I need a 15
level, but you know, I've only
cultivated 14. This is going to take a
lot of shoulder, chest, and everything
right on this arm. Okay? But look at
this
hand. So, just let this hand keep
turning. You guys see that? It does a
big
[Music]
try and blend your motion. So, you're
going to come
around and it takes you right into the
next step. Okay? Don't
have this movement. And then all you do
is move the arm up like this.
Okay, keep your figure eights going down
home Brown.
[Music]